[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
liste à démissionné après 44 jours
seulement au pouvoir la première
ministre britannique quitte donc son
poste 44 jours chaotique après la
présentation de son mini budget la
dégringolade de la livre sterling la
perte des fonds de pension britanniques
elle avait nommé à nouveau ministre des
Finances pour remplacer quasi quarteng
il avait même présenté ses excuses mais
tout cela n'a pas suffi sa mise de
l'Intérieur a d'ailleurs démissionné
hier listres a affirmé que son
successeur sera élu avant le vendredi 28
octobre le leader du Parti travailliste
qui est star meurt demande quant à lui
des élections anticipées alors on va
revenir bien sûr bien sûr sur ces 44
jours de mandats de list trust comment
expliquer sa chute qui pourrait lui
succéder quand dit le parti travailliste
des élections anticipées seront-elles
organisées et bien on en discute avec
mes invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés sera à boltaire bonsoir vous êtes
politiste ancienne responsable du lever
international à Paris c'est à dire c'est
la section du groupe parisien du Parti
travailliste bienvenue à vous
potomson merci d'être avec nous
président des conservateurs britanniques
à Paris bienvenue dans le débat Pascal
Jouannin est avec nous bonsoir
directrice générale de la Fondation
Robert Schuman et nous rejoindra dans
quelques minutes à Londres justement par
Skype Quantin Peel qui est un chercheur
associé au programme Europe de Chattam
house c'est donc le plus court mandat
historiquement je crois d'ailleurs d'une
première ministre d'un Premier ministre
britannique listraus a démissionné après
44 jours au pouvoir retour sur ces 44
jours
des marchés financiers qui paniquent une
monnaie nationale qui plonge détonne
intérêts qui s'envolent et en partie
conservateur qui se détournent d'elle
étant donné cette situation je ne peux
pas appliquer le programme sur lequel
j'ai été élu par le Parti conservateur
j'ai donc parlé à Sa Majesté le Roi pour
lui notifier le fait que je démissionne
comme chef du Parti conservateur
son discours aura duré moins de deux
minutes et son mandat moins de deux mois
le 5 septembre dernier liste remporte et
de très loin les voies des adhérents du
parti conservateurs et prend la tête de
la formation majoritaire à la chambre
dans la foulée Elisabeth delanme
première ministre la photo de sa
nomination est aussi la dernière de la
souveraine britannique fin septembre
après la période de deuil national elle
présente son mini budget principalement
des baisses d'impôts massives sans
explication sur leur financement qui
vont créer la panique trois semaines de
chaos sur les marchés financiers plus
tard liste se sépare de son ministre des
finances mais cela ne suffira pas sa
ministre de l'Intérieur démissionne et
le parti travailliste lui conserve une
avance de près de 30 points dans les
sondages
ils ont manqué alors devoir patriotiques
celui de garder le peuple britannique en
dehors de leur querelle pathétique et
cela a ruiné les finances de notre pays
la Grande-Bretagne ne peut plus se
permettre le chaos des conservateurs
nous avons besoin d'une élection
générale maintenant
pas d'élection générale mais de
nouvelles élections à la tête du Parti
conservateur pour remplacer la première
ministre des missionnaire elles auront
lieu d'ici le 28 octobre et Boris
Johnson pourrait présenter sa
candidature
puisque vous êtes le conservateur de ce
plateau je me tourne évidemment vers
vous vous avez l'air un peu en bas
embêté quand même un peu embarrassé non
je vois votre posture là sur le plateau
la situation est assez mauvaise pour ne
pas faire non ça c'est cette évidence
d'abord ce que j'ai lu cette après-midi
c'est qu'on était 36 %
derrière les travailler dans les
derniers sondages donc c'est encore pire
que ce que vous avez indiqué 36% donc
d'avance pour les travailler exactement
sur les sur le servateur s'il y avait
des élections de monde évolue bien
entendu mais c'est vrai que le fait de
choisir un nouveau leader et de le
remplacer un principe de temps fait des
autres c'est incontestable et si je
comprends bien 44 jours dans le c'est
très court en tout cas et est-ce qu'elle
avait très mal commencé ou pas parce que
la main a commencé oui avec son plan à
partir du 10e jour
elle a commis quand même
personnellement je ne pense pas qu'elle
devait être chassée comme ça et que on
aurait dû lui là c'est vraiment de temps
de
récupérer sa crédibilité mais qu'elle
avait droit à une deuxième chance vous
n'aurez je pense tout à fait si vous
regardez Emmanuel Macron par exemple il
a commis quelques gigantesques bourde
communication
affichant véritable mépris je ne pense
pas que ça correspond au fond de sa
pensée mais il a sorti des choses
absolument énormes exprimant mépris par
rapport aux gens modestes
et bien il est toujours en place
avec son plan économique ce n'est pas du
même du même genre ce que je veux dire
c'est que faire des erreurs même des
grandes erreurs
c'est très humain et et
quelques il faut savoir que elle n'était
pas le premier choix des députés
et de elle était loin derrière
Russie Sénac dans la première phase de
la sélection du remplaçant de de Boris
Johnson et je dois me demander s'il n'y
avait pas un certain nombre de députés
conservateurs qui dès le départ on dit
on attend un patiemment le moment de
ce que c'est eux qui ont eu sa tête
aujourd'hui je ne connais pas tous les
coups tous les affaires en coulisses
mais ça me paraît plausible comme
hypothèse en tout cas votre votre
analyse on sait qu'elle avait dégainé
avec wazy corteg donc son ministre des
Finances ce fameux plan qui a entraîné
de drame sur les marchés sur la livre
sterling mon cher donc à l'économie
britannique en général en fait ce qui
est très étonnant c'est que c'est
effectivement et là je suis d'accord
c'est beaucoup une révolution de palais
dans un d'une certaine mesure c'est un
conflit interne au conservateur qui a
about à son départ dans des conditions
très étranges on ne sait pas tellement
s'il y a un accord général sur une
vision d'ensemble on ne sait pas sur les
retraites il y a eu beaucoup de
variations d'un jour à l'autre et c'est
très déstabilisant parce qu'on est dans
une période de grande crise sociale et
économique et une crise également
internationale que connaissent aussi
beaucoup de pays qui se rajoutent à tout
ça donc vous vous pensez finalement
comme Monsieur Thomson qu'elle avait
droit à une deuxième chance que c'était
peut-être un peu hâtif je ne sais pas
je le fais qu'elle ait choisi de partir
maintenant c'est un peu son choix
n'est pas c'est dangereux c'est une ça
rajoute de l'instabilité à l'instabilité
et moi ce qui me dérange c'est qu'on va
être celui qui mélange surtout c'est de
choisir d'avoir un processus interne aux
parties conservateur qui va avoir lieu
alors il faut savoir que le précédent
processus interne a duré plus longtemps
en tout plus de 50 jours que son mandat
donc c'est quand même assez hallucinant
et qu'on soit suspendu à ces débats qui
semblent un peu absurde des déconnectés
de de ce qui est la réalité politique et
sociale à l'heure actuelle avec des
grèves très conséquentes en ce moment il
y a quelque chose de très déconnecté et
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec
somme qu'il faut absolument des
élections en général on va y revenir
justement sur l'interprétation encore un
mot Pascal Joanin sur vous qui êtes
européenne de ce plateau sur justement
ces erreurs qu'elle aurait commis quand
même
l'istre depuis le début
ah ben c'est pas que ce bon Lestre qui
commet des erreurs
célébritanniques depuis 2016 depuis le
brexit
les responsables principales erreurs a
été de sortir du brexit et c'était
soi-disant facile
bon on voit que le thé back control
c'est désastre donc ils arrivent pas à
reprendre le contrôle et on a en effet
les conservateurs excusez-moi monsieur
parce que c'est vous qui avez lancé le
référendum et c'est vous qui êtes au
pouvoir depuis 2010 qui avait
successivement
essayer de d'essayer de mettre en place
ce brexit on se souvient des difficultés
de théories mais alors après la chute de
Cameron à cause du référendum
Theresa ma affaire voter le plan de
sortie elle a lancé les élections qui se
sont un peu retournés contraire elle
avait une majorité elle en a plus là on
a eu Boris qui a gagné qui a gagné parce
que Boris était en effet celui qui
permettait d'avoir mais qui s'est fait
mettre dehors aussi pour son style
j'allais dire alors pour les erreurs de
communication qu'il a commises largement
là Monsieur Macron a battu à plat de
coupures barbarie James OK et puis on a
l'histoire alors l'histoire qu'on n'a
pas vu arriver il y avait en effet cinq
candidats en effet la troisième femme
première ministre après moi et Theresa
est toujours chez les conservateurs
d'ailleurs et en effet elle a essayé de
de tenir compte parce que c'est la
gagner c'est parce qu'elle avait donné
un petit peu du gras à moudre dans le
sens de ce que voulait les conservateurs
et donc c'est pour ça qu'elle a gagné
devant richessuna mais et ben voilà on
essaye de me mettre en place ce
programme et puis elle revient dessus la
situation économique je sais pas si en
effet elle a pas plus évolué qu'avant
mais enfin au mois de juin juillet
c'était déjà un peu tendu donc on a
l'impression qu'en effet il a gestion du
brexit et donc de de reprendre un peu le
contrôle et tu as désastre complet et
qu'on n'y arrive pas et je souhaite
bonne chance au successeur parce que je
ne suis pas sûr que quiconque arrivera
Paul Thompson est-ce que effectivement
le brexit est un peu responsable de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est un
stabilité
non pas du tout enfin à mon avis en tout
cas
alors vous êtes pas d'accord avec Pascal
de la Fondation remboursement depuis des
années et je sais que
œuvre pour la construction d'une Europe
forte et d'ailleurs
monsieur Juliani a écrit un super livre
prenant une bonne coopération en matière
de défense avec le Royaume-Uni même en
dehors de l'Union Européenne nous avons
toujours cette coopération parce qu'elle
est bilatérale elle n'est pas du tout et
donc il faut qu'on la maintienne
notamment mais sur le brexit
d'esprit positif
mais non je pense que le problème est
que il y a des différences de d'écoles à
l'intérieur du parti conserver comme
dans d'autres grands partis politiques
et parfois se devient brutal ce qui est
vrai c'est que le le processus du brexit
a grandement perturbé la vie politique
c'est un peu comme la Révolution
française
tu te propulsion gardée ça a peut-être
pas encore à couper la tête du roi
monsieur
c'est un Britannique repose normalement
sur la bon fonctionnement de convention
et le débats sur le brexit était
tellement
animé
passionné et pour chacun c'était
quasiment une question de vie ou de mort
que les institutions étaient carrément
bloquées pendant quelque chose qu'on
avait pas vu depuis je ne sais pas de
17e siècle depuis très très longtemps en
tout cas et et il y a c'est vrai qu'il y
a encore des retombées de ça de ce n'est
pas le la faute au Brasil lui-même c'est
cette perturbation
c'est parce que vous êtes sortis l'Union
européenne
elle a quand même il y a quand même eu
un rappel phénoménal des marchés du
président ou de la Banque d'Angleterre
qui a dit vous pouvez pas faire cette
politique donc c'est plus
si parce que quelque part il y a des
règles et le Royaume-Uni se retrouve un
peu tout seul il veut essayer de faire
quelque chose de nouveau etc et là
malheureusement ben on s'aperçoit que et
c'est les propres institutions
britanniques c'est même pas été les
autres qui ont dit mais non ça c'est
c'est vraiment dans le mur en klaxonnant
non parce que elle si je peux juste
répondre
le problème était un problème de marché
financier elle a sorti de façon
contraire aux habitudes ou à muni sont
mini budget qui n'avait pas été
vérifié par le
ob1000 qui normalement est le cas donc
ça c'est déjà très business
le ministre des Finances tous les deux
sont même consulter les autres membres
du cabinet qui ont concocté cette
assemblée de mesures assez assez forte
et donc
c'était ça
alors que elle
fait 11 ans donc c'était une façon de
faire qu'il donne un peu la méthode
n'était pas très sérieuse et sur le fond
était perçu comme étant problématique
parce qu'il y avait des fortes baisse
d'impôts qui n'étaient pas on n'a pas
expliqué comment on a le pays si on
avait dit on va certainement je vais
vous faire un certain nombre de
conservateurs étaient favorables à ce
plan certain oui
parce que il y avait une question c'est
il y avait une très mauvaise exécution
son idée de base on pouvait être pour ou
contre un n'était pas totalement
loufoque c'était il faut d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas très différent pourtant de ce
que la France a fait pour la situation
du corps mais la France était déjà très
endettée face à la covid la France a
augmenté sa dette nationale très
fortement pourquoi pour pour que le pays
puisse rester sur les reins il
s'agissait en fait de attendez Flora
Voltaire allez-y je pense que les les
deux réactions sont pas comparables
parce que c'est pas le même usage et
c'est pas pour faire les mêmes choses
mais mais pour le coup je pense qu'il y
a quelque chose ou finalement on vous a
tous les deux d'accord sur le fond et je
je dirais qu'en fait la campagne du
brexit a été complètement ridicule
c'est-à-dire on s'est affranchi
complètement des fêtes de la réalité de
l'analyse économique pour partir dans
une fuite en avant idéologique et
populiste pour pour certains et ça a
créé une nouvelle classe politique de de
gens très radicaux et je pense que le le
mini budget qui avait été proposé est
aussi une un exemple de fuite en avant
idéologique très dans une optique très
libérale qui a sa logique ça c'est
absolument incontestable mais qui était
qui était complètement enfin qui n'était
qui était déconnecté qui n'était pas
financière le FMI a mis en garde le
Royaume-Uni et le FMI c'est ça
c'était pas viable c'était le compte ne
tombait pas nous a rejoint en direct de
Londres chercheurs associés au programme
Europe de Chattam house ancien rédacteur
en chef à faire étrangère au final
bienvenue à vous Quantin si votre
réaction à cette démission vous prenez
un peu ce débat en route est-ce
qu'effectivement c'est lié à ces
problèmes de communication ou est-ce que
au contraire c'est lié au brexit quel
est votre analyse
alors je crois que la question
fondamentale c'est le parti conservateur
est en désastre c'est tout à fait divisé
et ça existe depuis le moment de brexit
les strass n'étaient pas la bonne
personne pour unifier le parti et aussi
il y avait le problème de Boris Jones
avant qui est aussi alors il n'y a
personne qui ont pu réunir le Parti
conservateur et on a un moment où ce
parti a une majorité assez grande dans
le Parlement mais ne peut pas gouverner
et ne peut pas trouver une personne pour
devenir Premier ministre alors ce que
nous ce nous avons besoin d'une élection
une élection nationale c'est les
conservateurs du Parti travailliste qui
demande une élection nationale mais dont
et c'est interne au parti conservateur
c'est ce que vous dites quanti on va
écouter Emmanuel Macron qui il s'agit à
cette démission de listrot
dans la vie politique britannique mais
je veux dire que j'ai eu l'occasion à
plusieurs reprises de rencontrer listrus
nous avons encore échangé cette semaine
et ça vient de relation de travail qui
se construisait et je souhaite que en
tout cas la Grande-Bretagne puisse
trouver le plus rapidement possible la
stabilité allait de l'avance et c'est
bon pour nous et c'est bon pour notre
Europe voilà parle de stabilité alors
c'est intéressant parce qu'en général on
parle d'instabilité pour l'Italie pas
vraiment pour le Royaume-Uni donc c'est
tout de même effectivement assez
surprenant ce qui se passe au
Royaume-Uni les institutions ne sont pas
sur le point de s'écrouler et elles sont
très anciennes elles remontent même
pas en Italie non plus d'ailleurs mais
bon mais il a eu une succession de
République et de régime des versets
variés depuis le 19ème siècle mais bon
ce n'est pas vraiment le stabilité ça
commence entre le mot qui colle au
Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui
à l'intérieur du parti conservateur
actuellement il y a une
effervescence d'un stabilité
c'est un indéniable je pense que la
situation va se calmer il a eu d'autres
moments
ou du très grand débat au 19e siècle
entre l'industrie et l'agriculture il y
avait des débats extrêmement animés au
sein du Parti conservateur du début
au début du 20e siècle aussi entre le
protectionnisme le libre commerce
donc ça fait partie de la vie politique
quand même qu'il y a des moments où les
choses sont sont très chaudes alors donc
le leader du Parti travailliste demande
des élections Quantin pilossi parlent
d'élection générale vous également en
Flora boltaire vous pensez que
effectivement s'il y avait d'abord
comment est-ce avec les institutions en
britannique comment est-ce qu'on peut
déclarer que demain il va y avoir des
élections générales je pense que c'est
pas si simple vous nous dirons vous
allez
ça a été simplifié et voilà ça serait la
solution pour le parti Travis qui
évidemment en tête des sondages pour
l'instant ce n'est pas du tout ce que
souhaite le Parti conservateur à tout à
fait c'est d'ailleurs une difficulté et
pour le coup il y a une demande qui
vient de très nombreux acteurs également
la la première ministre d'Écosse à ses
prononcé en faveur de nouvelles
élections il y a un système qui a été
simplifié avant il fallait une majorité
qualifiée de deux tiers il me semble à
la Chambre des communes elle a c'est un
tout petit peu plus simple c'est une
requête qui est faite au Roi par le
Premier ministre ou la première ministre
qui est qui ensuite peut entraîner peut
entraîner une élection assez rapidement
ça a été relativement simplifié dans les
années dans les dernières années pour
l'instant effectivement été testé sur ce
nouveau format et c'est la première fois
en fait depuis
sa première fois qu'il y a deux
changements comme ça successifs de
Premier ministre depuis une élection qui
pourtant n'est pas si ancienne on est
bien d'accord mais la dernière fois que
c'est arrivé c'était que c'était en 1940
et là il y avait une bonne raison pour
ne pas faire d'élections il y avait il y
avait une crise enfin il y avait une
situation d'ampleur ici on est dans une
situation où à mon avis si on veut
sortir de ce conflit interne permanent
et de ses révolutions de palais qui
continuent et qui impactent durablement
l'économie et qui empêche finalement
d'avancer à l'heure actuelle oui les
institutions sont résilientes bien sûr à
l'échelle de l'histoire elles sont
résignantes ça ne veut pas dire que ça
permette d'avoir des solutions en temps
utile pour les gens concrètement dans
leur vie de tous les jours s'agissant
des retraites s'agissant des loyers
s'agissant de tout un des prix de
l'énergie et des transports c'est ça qui
est difficile parce qu'elle joint non
c'est vrai que des élections générales
au Royaume-Uni pourraient effectivement
peut-être ah bah ça mérite de la clarté
parce que là on voit bien que d'abord
les élections ils ont eu lieu en 2019
donc elle devrait avoir lieu en 2024
pour noter l'esprits 2024 donc c'est à
la fin de la neige avait eu lieu en
décembre donc normalement les Anglais
fallait britanniques peuvent en effet
faire des élections anticipées au moment
où ils le veulent Theresa May en affect
etc donc il n'est pas impossible de
faire des élections anticipées c'est un
peu le choix et on essaie de le faire à
un moment où ça porte alors je vois bien
qu'aujourd'hui c'est des sondages sont
bons que les conservateurs n'ont pas du
tout envie d'aller aux élections
puisqu'il prendrait une une sérieuse
revers et donc ils peuvent pas y aller
maintenant en effet il faut souvenir que
les stress n'a pas été élu par Boris
Johnson était élu par par une élection
et Theresa May qui avait succédé à David
Cameron était à avait aussi souhaité
avoir une onction populaire pour dire
voilà j'ai le peuple dernièrement là ce
ne sont que les membres du Parti
conservateur c'est pas faire offense on
a aussi la procédure de décision dans
certains partis politiques mais ça ne
représente qu'à petit nombre de
personnes et donc ce sont les militants
qui ont choisi parmi 5 candidats les
stress au mois de juillet et là on nous
dit qu'en une semaine une semaine de 28
octobre c'est le vendredi prochain que
il serait capable de ou la famille
douane je ne sais pas qui sera
suffisamment et ce que n'ont pas fait
les autres prédécesseurs qui avaient eu
le temps de faire campagne etc donc je
suis pas sûr que même le successeur qui
en avait un la semaine prochaine pour
réduire très longtemps donc ces
élections se sont pas lieu maintenant
elles sont vouées à avoir lieu avant
2024 pour le pour la solidarité pour la
solide la stabilité du Royaume-Uni Paul
Thompson vous pensez effectivement que
là s'il y a nominé enfin élection d'un
nouveau Premier ministre conservateur
dans les 10 jours qui viennent ça veut
dire une vocation à l'instabilité que il
sera parce que justement il n'aura pas
de légitimité réelle il faut faire ces
élections générales anticipées
ça ne veut pas du tout dire qu'il faut
des élections générales d'anticiper et
dans la plupart des pays y compris la
France mais ça devrait en Allemagne
aussi par exemple il y a on a imposé un
régime avec une régularité presque
absolue en France il peut y avoir une
dissolution avant le terme c'est très
rare
[Musique]
c'est tout à fait certain qu'il y a eu
une il y a eu une phase d'instabilité au
parti travail c'est absolument certain
tous les partis en ont après après c'est
pas du tout la même situation parce que
le parti travaille ce n'était pas au
pouvoir parce que ça parce que les les
gags comme le mini budget ne coûte pas
des dizaines de milliards à l'économie
avec des des annonces et des effets de
fuite de la plupart des des des banques
et des grandes des grandes entreprises
on a vraiment eu un impact très lourd de
ce genre de décision donc pour le coup
oui il y a eu tout un travail qui a été
fait un travail de fond aujourd'hui on
est Unis aujourd'hui le parti
travailliste et pourtant j'ai été très
critique notamment de Jeremy Corben et
voilà je ne suis plus en responsabilité
aussi pour ça mais aujourd'hui il y a
tout un travail qui a été fait et on a
une certaine stabilité une équipe qui
est à peu près d'accord donc vous vous
dites vous êtes prêts aller travailler
stockwenty Peel est-ce que vous pouvez
réagir justement si effectivement il y
avait des élections générales on sur ce
plateau que ce serait plutôt y
travailler c'est un qui sont loin devant
les conservateurs c'est la raison pour
laquelle aussi les conservateurs ne
veulent pas déclencher d'élections
générales est-ce que les travailleurs
seraient prêts à reprendre le pouvoir et
après on va parler de ce qui se passe au
sein des parties conservateurs
ils ne sont pas énormément enthousiastes
devant la question de parce qu'ils
auront probablement après des élections
une majorité une très grande et dans un
tel situation les divisions dans le
parti travail même elles sont un peu les
mêmes que les divisions dans le Parti
conservateur entre droite et gauche et
il y aura un problème mais quand même je
crois que
custom alors il se présente comme une
personne très sérieuse et il pourrait
devenir Premier ministre il se présente
comme ça il est sérieux beaucoup plus
sérieux en ce moment que les
possibilités du côté conservateur
c'est ce que vous pensez côté
conservateur justement Quantin Peel
puisque
là on parle de 10 jours pour mettre en
place un nouveau une nouvelle Première
ministre est-ce que ça vous semble
possible probable effectivement c'était
quand même beaucoup plus long la
procédure précédente
c'est possible c'est possible que si il
faut que la personne qui qui va être élu
à au moins sans voix des parlementaires
et si seulement une personne à 100 voix
pour ce candidat
il ou elle deviendrait Premier ministre
la semaine prochaine alors c'est
possible mais quand même ça c'est
vraiment ça pourrait être très difficile
envers la population parce que c'est
très clair des sondages que plus de 70%
veulent des élections générales alors
justement si vous vous réagissez à cela
Paul Thomson la population qui
effectivement majoritairement voudrait
des élections générales un parti
conservateur qui va organiser quand même
très rapidement ces élections moi j'ai
vu d'après les dernières dépêches que
ils limiteraient les candidats à 3 déjà
et qui aurait déjà un premier tour lundi
un résultat de premier tour dès lundi là
donc c'est extrêmement
[Musique]
gate il pourrait revenir il a été chassé
par les conservateurs il a pas été
chassé
il y a un problème je ne sais pas
britannique donc je peux pas je prends
pas par entre le débat qui qui vous
anime je ne sais pas britannique mais on
voit bien que Boris Johnson a été chassé
par les conservateurs et il y a eu ce
congrès où il y a eu un effet des
candidats etc et donc là on voit encore
une fois c'est bien les conservateurs et
les dissensions les démissions des
conservateurs qui obligent madame
l’estos c'est pas l'opinion publique
c'est pas la pression de la rue il y a
pas eu des manifestations devant le 10
derniers week en disant comme il y en
avait eu par la madame facia et donc là
on a bien en effet un gros problème de
de de de stabilité du Parti conservateur
pour trouver l'homme ou la famille
douane qui permettra en effet d'unir ce
parti pour une pour le bien de du
Royaume-Uni parce qu'en effet vous avez
raison il faut que le Royaume-Uni sorte
de cette crise mais je vois pas trop qui
est aujourd'hui comme il y a déjà un
congrès il y a deux mois celui qui
serait derrière le rideau qu'on n'avait
pas encore vu et qui serait l'homme et
l'homme ou la famille doit avec moi
il est dans la course mais il y a deux
personnes revenir ça c'est sûr il y a
deux personnes qui pourraient assumer
cette lourde tâche et le mener à bien je
pense oui
elle avait emporté largement au-dessus
de lui la dernière fois l'histoire
ne concernant que les députés il a été
loin devant oui et Penny morte qui est
qui est une figure assez unificatrice je
crois
c'est elle qui est chargée des relations
avec le Parlement je n'ai pas en tête sa
position mais c'est une parole de du
Parti conservateur qui est très respecté
qui a beaucoup de
caractères beaucoup de personnalité et
[Musique]
contre le fait qu'on a deux premiers
ministres quand même trois secrétaires
d'État aux Affaires intérieures et
quatre chancelets de l'échiquier en
quatre mois enfin voilà enfin quand on
n'est pas habitué à au climat
britannique et qu'on est on se dit mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
du Channel il y a vraiment un ouragan
qui est en train d'emporter la vie
politique et il faut faire attention
parce que ça ça peut être très dangereux
voltor cet ouragan
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'assez pas
complètement inouï mais c'est quand même
très rapide et c'est quand même très
déstabilisant par beaucoup d'aspects à
tous les niveaux et je pense aux
administrations qui doivent s'adapter à
tout à tous les services en fait de
l'État qui dépendent de ça et qui
dépendent de ses choix et qui sont
effectivement on a l'impression que
c'est un petit choix qui a lieu entre
membres du Parti conservateur et
particulièrement les parlementaires bien
évidemment et avec une aile droite aussi
qui est très forte à l'intérieur du
parti conservateurs et qui est aussi une
des raisons une des démissions qui ont
eu lieu et qui qui ont eu lieu cette
semaine donc au sein du gouvernement
c'était aussi des gens qui incarnaient
une ligne très dure à la fois
économiquement et en termes de de
société en terme de choix de de vision
de la société globalement et c'est aussi
quelque chose qui rajoute une complexité
de plus dans un parti qui est qui semble
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus morcelé qu'il
y a quelques années et le seul
finalement c'est le dernier qui a tenté
son mandat ou qui a obtenu son mandat
des électeurs c'était borles Johnson là
on a eu un changement avec avec la
première ministre là si on change de
nouveau le mandat est de plus en plus
éloigné des électeurs alors après c'est
c'est un choix qui certes un combat
l'équipe et sortante mais c'est un choix
partisan pour les intérêts d'un parti je
ne pense pas que ce soit l'intérêt du
royaume que ce soit les travailler ce
qui est choisi le nouveau leader
une élection et que donc ce soit les
électeurs qui choisissent-ils vous
pouvez réagir est-ce qu'effectivement on
disait un petit problème institutionnel
là aussi
oui c'est clair parce qu'il n'y a pas de
système pour pour résoudre ce problème
et c'est seulement si le gouvernement
perd une vote importante ou bien sur le
budget ou bien question de confiance
qu'on a des élections alors si on n'a
pas la possibilité d'élection mais le
Parti conservateur n'est pas uni et ne
peut pas gouverner alors là il y aura
cette roi peut-être au hasard de décider
qu'il faut changer quand même le
gouvernement mais ça serait une décision
énorme
est constitutionnelle ah bon mais ça
serait possible donc que le roi prenne
une telle décision ce serait totalement
inédit non au Royaume-Uni alors si on
trouve une situation où vraiment il n'y
a pas de Premier ministre qui a une
majorité au Parlement dans son propre
parti ou sa propre partie là il y aura
un problème vraiment constitutionnel
toutes ces questions reviennent pour
nous depuis ce fameux référendum depuis
le brexit donc c'est ce que disait
Pascal Johanna parce que vous avez raté
le début du débat elle disait c'est à
tout ça c'est à cause du brexit c'est
votre analyse aussi oui je crois bien
alors c'est une question très importante
parce que le référendum il avait le
Parti conservateur et les gens qui
voulaient le brexit qui ont dit dès le
commencement nous ne voulons pas
entendre des experts nous voulons
seulement c'est une question de
idéologie et ce
alors les auteurs britanniques n'aiment
pas les idéologies effectivement ils
veulent beaucoup plus les pragmatistes
et les conservateurs ont perdu leur
pragmatisme les conservateurs ont perdu
leur pragmatisme vous pouvez réagir Paul
Thompson vous êtes d'accord avec Quantin
Peel non je ne suis pas d'accord je sais
que la FT était à bataillé très
énergiquement le brexit pendant toute la
campagne et pendant les deux ans suivant
également pour essayer de s'ouvertir le
résultat et bon tout à fait le choix de
la FT de définir sa ligne éditoriale
bien évidemment
cette opposition entre dogmatiques
idéologique et pragmatique
on pourrait dire que les antibrexites
étaient les idéologues parce qu'il
refusait d'accepter que l'idée de se
désinsérer un peu de ces structures
internationales comme l'Union européenne
à refuser d'accepter que ça puisse être
une option même envisageable
c'est plutôt ça du dogmatisme je pense
mais
comme je l'ai déjà dit peut-être avant
l'arrivée de
Monsieur pile
je pense qu'il est faux de mélanger la
question du brexit et de ses problèmes
de
encore une fois c'était plutôt un
problème de mauvais exécution de
mauvaises communication et peut-être
pour le coup
c'est ça qui a causé son
sa chute elle a mal communiqué et elle
avait une approche un peu trop
idiologique là je pense que c'est vrai
un peu trop libertaire pour le coup on
jurant que par les marchés par les
entreprises etc donc la vie d'un pays
est beaucoup plus complexe que c'était
une idéologue listrot
je ne dirais pas qu'elle était
généralement
son action depuis qu'elle a été choisie
comme premier ministre a été trop
emprunte d'une certaine idéologie
libérale libertaire je pense et elle n'a
pas voulu
prendre en compte la complexité des
problèmes à régler y compris la possible
réaction des marchés financiers le fait
que la même pas consulté le cabinet est
absolument scandaleux donc
mais ça c'est du mot travail c'est de
mauvais
manque de professionnels et pas plutôt
et pas aux trois autres choses
vous vous réagissez est-ce
qu'effectivement les conservateurs sont
moins pragmatiques qu'avant le brexit ce
que disait petit une génération
politique montante qui a été créée par
le moment du référendum sur le brexit
qui est parti en disant des choses
complètement fausses démontré donc dont
on pouvait démontrer qu'elles étaient
fausses sur les sommes qu'on
économiserait en ne faisant pas partie
de l'Union européenne sur les
perspectives de conclure des accords
avec d'autres pays sur l'innocuité de
supprimer le fondement d'une bonne
partie de la législation et de la
réglementation enfin énormément de
choses qui sont qui sont assez
hallucinantes d'un point de vue de
rapport avec la réalité et qui aimait ça
n'est pas malheureusement il n'y a pas
que aux parties conservateurs pour le
coup c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve
un peu partout en Europe aussi en ce
moment avec qui a effectivement
effectivement qui est monté sur une
forme très idéologique en tout cas le
mini budget était de l'idéologie pure
même du même
qu'il était très idéologique ce budget
un mot Pascal Johanna justement sur ils
sont moins pragmatique qu'avant ah mais
c'est une des premières une des
premières manifestations du populisme en
Europe a été le brexit alors après nous
a eu Trump c'est aux États-Unis il y a
eu d'autres choses mais c'était vraiment
une manifestation et ce takeba control
qu'on a eu comme motus etc alors que là
excusez-moi mais on a l'impression que
le conservateur perdent le contrôle de
tout et que il y a une instabilité qui
est moi j'ai une je suis pas très
vieille mais on a eu Margat Thatcher 11
ans on a eu Tony Blair quasiment 13 ans
là on avait David Cameron qui était là
pour 6 ans et puis là depuis 6 ans on
voit une valse de Premier ministre de de
tout ce conservateur bien évidemment
mais avec des difficultés à trouver
rassembler le parti etc et donc je là je
me dis mais on est à la quatrième et
quatrième première ministre depuis Camon
et on se voit qu'est-ce qui va se passer
après et donc je me dis que les deux ans
qui ne sait pas le du terme normal des
élections vont être très très
tant ça va tanguer de au Royaume-Uni et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'en effet le Parti
conservateur est aujourd'hui l'ossature
et là et la possibilité de trouver
quelqu'un qui fasse la la l'unité et que
donc en effet il faudra peut-être un
jour en retourner devant les urnes parce
qu'en effet à la fin c'est le peuple qui
choisit-il juste je vous fais réagir
qu'est-ce qui va se passer maintenant là
puisque on va rentrer justement dans ces
journées de turbulences d'élection donc
un nouveau ou d'une nouvelle Premier
ministre
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
pardon qu'est-ce qui va passer
maintenant
on va rentrer dans un donc un moment
d'élection au sein du Parti conservateur
oui au sein pour commencer au sein des
parlementaires et il faut sortir de
candidats encore une fois pour le parti
mais on espère dans le Parti
conservateur qu'il n'y aura qu'un
candidat et à la fin on va dire bon on
va couronner les candidats et on aura ce
candidat tout seul la semaine prochaine
mais si ça va marcher comme ça le favori
en ce moment c'est richissounac et qui
était numéro la dernière fois mais
peut-être que paiement donne et l'autre
possibilité je crois que Boris Johnson
c'est fini ils ne peuvent pas revenir
vous dites ça vous et votre analyse Paul
Thomson sur les quelques jours à venir
ça va être quand même un peu turbulent
chez les conservateurs
où il y a déjà regisounac est déjà je
pense qu'il est déjà élu avant d'être
élu je pense qu'il y aura un processus
certes court me relativement ordonné qui
va se dérouler et le fait que ce c'est
vrai qu'une semaine c'est très court en
soi cette recours normalement mais il y
a déjà eu la campagne pendant tout l'été
et c'est vraiment très récent justement
donc
dans ces circonstances très
particulières je pense que une semaine
probablement suffisante et je suis
d'accord je l'ai déjà dit moi-même
d'ailleurs que les deux favoris sont les
deux personnes
richesse unique et
ces deux personnes sont
consensuel ça peut être
trop dur mais ils sont capables de d'une
heure assez large partie du parc du
conserveau et si il
remettent les choses sur les reins et ça
va ça peut vite quand même la situation
c'est que si vous êtes sur un navire qui
a l'air d'être en train de couler
c'est un peu inquiétant les gens
deviennent très nerveux ah merci le
nouveau leader
à faire preuve d'autorité et aussi c'est
parler aux différentes
écoles différentes groupes dans le Parti
conservateur il peut ramener ramener
l'autre chez sunac qui est reconnu comme
étant très intelligent il était propre
site tout en étant quelqu'un de très
proche des marchés financiers
donc et il a
suffisant voilà on va bien on verra bien
ils peuvent reprendre la main c'est
celui qui était le deuxième derrière
je peux dire qu'il y avait une lég déjà
il y a trois mois et tout se déroulement
confirme exactement la ligne qu'elle a
pris dans la dans la campagne parce
qu'il a dit il faut être sérieux même si
sur les questions économiques pendant
ce qui va reprendre la main si c'est lui
effectivement a été élu il est possible
qu'il reprenne la main mais ce que ce
qui m'étonne toujours c'est que on est
en train de de de commenter un débat
interne ou une histoire interne ou
finalement très peu de gens vont prendre
vont prendre part et qui est au final ça
me semble complètement hors de propos et
hors de contact avec une réalité qui est
faite quand même qui est très dur avec
des mouvements de grève un peu partout
une très forte inflation un des
difficultés vraiment profondes le
pouvoir n'appartient ni aux parties
conservateur ni au parti travailler
style appartient aux citoyens et c'est
pour le coup ils sont encore une fois
difficilement on peut difficilement s'en
sortir oui mais on a changé depuis le
premier ministre et là on va changer une
deuxième fois
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
Paul Thompson merci beaucoup Flora
boltaire merci Pascal Joanin Merci à
VOUS Quantin tills d'avoir été avec nous
en direct de Londres merci à vous tous
de nous avoir suivis et vous restez avec
nous sur France 24
[Musique]